all right music's going down looks like
we're ready to begin we got our slides
going it's 5:40 last session of the day
hopefully everybody's brain is already
full of knowledge juice at this point
we're gonna take a deeper look at blazer
today my name is Ryan Nowak I'm a
developer and architect on asp net core
and this is hello I'm Steve Sanderson
yeah I'm also same kind of thing as Ryan
we've been working together for how long
now a year and a half three or four
years it seemed something about quite
wide range yet so and engineer number
one an engineer number two on blazer up
here so agenda today what are we gonna
do I'm gonna have a short presentation
about blazer server we're going to talk
about how that works and lots of juicy
details about that a lot of that
information applies to blazer client as
well but since we just shipped blazer
server I'm mostly going to be talking
about that and Steve is going to show us
yeah I'm gonna give you some more
advanced demos about some things
relating to authorization and
authentication which we don't normally
get to talk about yeah so all of the
content today is going to be slightly on
the advanced side so if you're here
hopefully you've heard of blazer so far
this is not going to be an introductory
talk this is going to be some more deep
technical in-depth content and hopefully
that is useful to you or at least
entertaining for you I think there's
lots of cool technical stuff to learn
about here so let's get started
so Blazer server how does it work
today what we're going to talk about
with respect to blazer server is sort of
a progression of from the point where
you write your code to the point where
the DOM is updating in the UI how does
that process work addition what's going
to fall out of that is some information
about Blazer performance and the design
of how the Blazer rendering process
works as well as how to think about the
scale of blazer server in production and
this is a deep dive to be totally clear
into details that you don't really need
to know so not an introductory course
not necessarily a deep reflection of how
to program Blazer or best practices for
architecture but if you're the kind of
person who likes really detailed
information and you like to know all the
low-level secret details this might be
useful to you and it might help you
understand and get a better appreciation
for what's in Blazer and hopefully it's
still fun for everybody and you can
learn
something and tickle that part of your
brain so at a high level how does blazer
server work you write C sharp and or
Razer code it runs on the server in a
dotnet core process
so remember blazer server is not the web
assembly flavor of blazer it's the
dotnet core flavor of blazer and then
though that rendering process that
blazer process your application running
in a dotnet core process is going to
update the UI and a browser somewhere
else on the Internet ooh we do that via
signal are usually over a WebSocket
connection so we can send you eye
updates from your server to somebody
sitting in their house or on their phone
or somewhere else and we're gonna look
at questions like how can this work and
how can this be done in a performant way
a lot of that information and those sort
of motivating design details that make
Blazer server work are true of both web
assembly and server and laser server was
something we invented well after we had
figured out blazer web assembly so
that's why it has so much in common and
you'll find that a lot of the details
that are common to Blazer are pivotal to
how this can even work in the server
side model so if you're the kind of
person who likes diagrams here's a nifty
diagram on the left we've got our asp
net core process we've got blazer
running on top of your components
running on top of net in.net core 3 oh
and you've got the signal our
communication channel that is talking to
a browser somewhere with a Dom again
signal our is that real-time WebSocket
based communication framework this is
how we push Dom updates into a browser
and this is how we get UI updates our UI
events from a browser as well as things
like J's Interop or any other kinds of
things that we need to make blaze of
server work with the browser I'll go
over that WebSocket channel so when
you're writing your blazer code it's
gonna look something like this right we
are inside the the counter component
here and I have got another component
that I'm using here which I'm calling
fancy span which is a fancy sort of span
and that's basically the only
modification that I have made to this
from the default template I'm going to
switch to that because I've got that
over here and just give that a run for
y'all you can ignore that for now so I'm
gonna go to the counter page I've got
this very exciting fancy
ban here and when I click the counter
it's gonna go back and forth between
bold Wow that's powerful weekend right
revolutionary everyone is going to want
apps that are either bold or not
incredibly valuable so this is our sort
of motivating example for today and it's
not really that impressive or that
complicated and that's great because
it's a great opportunity to dig into
these low-level details and see kind of
how blazer works on a fundamental level
there's not a lot of complexity in the
sample which is hopefully going to help
everybody sort of understand the
principles here so blazer at its core is
based on a bunch of different primitives
and I'm gonna kind of flip back and
forth between the code and this thing so
you can see what those are so we have
primitives in blazer like elements those
are your HTML tags we have primitives in
blazer like components that's where you
render another component and use its
output and compose with it we have
primitive it's in blazer like attributes
attributes can either be parameters that
are passed to a component or they can be
attributes on an HTML element and just
we also have content and content is well
it's content it's just the raw text
output the things that are gonna show up
in the DOM is plain text
now we also have some high-level
constructs like events and at bind and
at on click generally most of your
high-level constructs in Blazer are
going to map to attributes so there are
probably some special cases there
probably some things that I forgot if
Steve feels like mentioning them he will
but everything that we're going to look
at today for the most part either is one
of these four primitives on the top or
maps to an attribute so if I flip back
to this I can identify some of these
things so up here we've got an element
right here we've got a component you can
tell it's a component because upper case
and it's bold up here we've got an
attribute we sort of think about
attributes being passed to components
and attributes being passed to elements
that's like really similar things here
we've got some content inside of here
and this text that's being evaluated
here this expression that's being
evaluated here when you see at something
it's c-sharp code that's going to run
and produce a value in Blaser that's
actually content - it's just content
that's going to be done
ethically computed likewise this c-sharp
expression here these at parentheses
thing that's inside of this attribute is
just the value of that attribute so
we've got all these different kinds of
primitives that we talked about before
some some things that probably don't
fall into that primitive category that
are going to be mapped to attributes are
like this at unclick attribute here what
is that so when you see at in front of
an attribute in Blaser that's something
we refer to as a directive attribute and
there's a couple different categories of
those that you'll see and they all
represent like power like they're all
like some kind of superpower or
something like that so add on click in
this case means this is the C sharp
version of the onclick event handler for
this button likewise the fact that we
can nest content inside of this fancy
span we put some static text in here you
could put other components in here other
rendering logic in here and the that's
that's like a special kind of value that
will be passed to that fancy span so
enough of looking at the code I promised
a deep dive and deep dive we shall so
what does the compiler do so a lot of
what I spend my time on when I'm working
on blazer is writing this compiler along
with some other people on the team and
thinking about well when you write all
that code and that razor file what does
this turn into what does it output what
does it do how does it behave so the way
that dot razor files work is they
actually get compiled to c-sharp so all
of the all of the app expressions that
are in your c-sharp they appear in like
special positions in some generated
c-sharp file and then those generated
c-sharp files are passed to the compiler
along with your other c-sharp files and
ultimately make your assembly so if you
inspect this code and you're very
careful you will see those four
primitives that we talked about here
represented you'll see elements you'll
see content you'll see attributes you'll
see components there's a component and
you'll see those four primitives show up
here right likewise the content that we
passed to that fancy span component is
actually represented as a attribute that
has a value that contains a dotnet
lambda so that's how composition
generally kind of works in Blaser and at
its core it all just goes back to those
four primitives everything is either
elements components attributes or
content
so the job of the compiler is basically
to understand the code you wrote and
turn all of that structure into those
four primitives the generated code when
it's executed which is the thing that we
just looked at is going to produce a
data structure that primarily contains
those four primitives so if you think
about what's going to be in there it's
going to be that the fact that it's an
element and the element name the fact
that it's a component and the component
type the fact that it's an attribute and
its name and value and we call this
process of rendering so if you look at a
component class and it's got a build
render tree method or we hear us talking
about rendering rendering the pro is the
process of executing all of the code
that's in here that's not inside the
code block and getting its output so
what does it output well we can look at
that too
I captured this data earlier today using
Steve's cool unit testing prototype that
he showed during his talk if you're
really smart and you feel up to it you
can try just building a component
writing a unit test and then set a
breakpoint inside that renderer and you
can see what the renderer actually works
with so I have simplified things and I
have tried to sort of extract the parts
of this that are useful for teaching so
that we can look at them and this is the
output of rendering the component that
we've been looking at that counter
component and that fancy span and doing
its first render and getting kind of its
snapshot what is all the Dom what is all
of those four primitives that we produce
from that first render so you can see
we're inside the counter component here
on the Left we have some markup one of
the optimizations that we do in Blaser
is that when you contain when you have
elements attributes and content that are
entirely static within the page like
this h1 banner that contains the text
counter we'll sort of reduce that into a
single node for the purposes of
optimization so don't let that throw you
then you can see we open an element here
that's div then you can see we open the
fancy span and so on and so on and so on
it's all those four primitives on the
right-hand side you see the rendering
output of the fancy span both of these
two components produce their own
independent sets of frames so an
important takeaway or conclusion from
this to understand about how components
work is that each component
his own set of frames it has its own
output and they're independent and gets
stitched together later shall we say why
its frames are not a kind of tree
structure please okay right so when this
stuff is getting rendered we've got a
big array in memory that we can fill up
with these render frames so as we're
going through invoking each of these
instructions in the render method that
adds a frame into this array and we keep
going through populate in that array now
that's not the most obvious way to do it
a more obvious way would be to build up
a kind of hierarchical tree structure
where every time you add a new okhla new
element will you know create an element
instance and then we'll recursively
start populating that and build a big
recursive data graph in memory and we
could totally have done that but that
wouldn't have performed anywhere near as
well because it would be constantly
allocating for every single thing it
needs in that tree structure and so as a
pretty important optimization for us we
want rendering to not allocate memory it
should operate other fixed buffers of
data and that's why we've got these
these arrays of frames that we populate
and and it makes things look a lot more
complicated and it is but you know you
don't have to worry about that for your
normal programming tasks yeah
so everything that Steve just mentioned
is true by the way Surrender frames are
what we call the output of building the
rendering tree it's a declarative format
and the great thing about render frames
is a format is it's very efficient as
Steve mentioned and it's very efficient
for doing a bunch of things that we care
about you can very efficiently turn it
over turn it into HTML in oh of n
operation so a single pass over the
frames and you can very very efficiently
diff outputs of render frames so if you
have two sets of render frames that come
from the same components it's designed
for diffing
now I didn't mention these numbers and
some of you probably wondered what these
numbers were I'm not going to give it an
extremely detailed explanation of how
this works but the numbers exist as an
aid to the diffing system so they
basically what the numbers map to is the
line of code effectively the logical
line of code that produced this render
frame and the way that that works is
when you have conditions in the
generated code or you have conditions in
your code or loops in your code those
sequence numbers will reflect the
control flow that took place when you
executed the application and will help
in diffing
who so in general why do we care about
dipping we care about dipping because of
two things
because in Blazer server we're gonna
send the diffs or send Dom updates over
the network we want it to be the most
efficient set of data the smallest set
of data that's necessary to get the
output that you want the other reason
why we care about dipping is both for
Blazers server and for blazer
webassembly Dom updates are very
comparatively expensive to all the other
things that we're doing here things like
running your rendering method or
building the render tree or doing the
diff itself are actually fairly cheap
compared to doing things like updating
the Dom so we'd like to avoid updating
the Dom when necessary and we'd also
like to ensure that we can transmit the
minimal amount of information so I think
Steve mentioned a lot of these things
already so I won't go into this in I
won't read my own slides at you but the
important part here that I think is is
to explain in a little bit more detail
as what is on the right so each
component has its own set of frames that
come out as its output and just like
that each component is is designed to
sort of render independently from the
rest of system so the way that the
render infrastructure is is is designed
is we queue up components for rendering
during the rendering process of a
component it might trigger other
components to render and we basically
try to find the minimal set that needs
to render and execute them in order
until there's nothing left so what
causes a component to render what causes
a component to update its State when I
say render you should think update state
right when I click that button
something went bold inside the fancy
span and something went bold inside the
counter the kinds of things that make a
component render are first of all its
initial creation second of all when
parameters change third when an event
happens and fourth arbitrary reasons
that you decide the most common one
being things like background timers or
other kinds of notifications that come
from your app code ultimately it's the
component that decides when to render
itself if you're using razor code to
author components or you're inheriting
from component base you're getting all
these behaviors by default as well so
who renders in our example I clicked I
click the increment count button and we
saw that we saw that the current count
changed
which implies that we would need to
render this page the counter page and we
also saw that the fancy span toggles
every time you click from bold to not
bold and back and so on
so can we figure out why we render well
this component has to render because it
handled in event so we click the on
click button increment count is a method
on this class and so we're ear under the
counter component then when we're
rerender encountered component we
evaluate this expression we compare that
to the previous value of is bold and we
see that that has changed and so the
fancy span also has to render so each of
these rendering decisions is somewhat
independent from each other and tries to
be efficient and do the minimal amount
of work when necessary in this case
something we're passing into the fancy
span said hey you've got to update
because the value is different so how
does the dip I'm not gonna go an
incredible incredible detail about the
different how the different works I
think Steve might have a few things to
say about it
we've got some awesome documentation for
it it's called the source code you can
read that generally generally the bus
with the different code I have to
acknowledge this is difficult for me I'm
gonna take a moment the bus factor on
diffing code is very high Steve and
Javier are I think the only people who
really understand what's going on there
and maybe maybe I'm being generous to to
Javier anyway if Europe sinks into the
sea
expect a rewrite of blazer anyway so
what the dipping process the diffing
process basically batches through lists
of frames that are known to have come
from the same component and what it
outputs is a different set of
instructions so it's a set of
instructions to basically turn the
current state into the future state so
these are these are the diff outputs
from clicking that button and we'll do
the right side first because it's really
simple the right side produces one diff
one diff instruction not one diff one
diff instruction and it says set
attribute and then it will have a
pointer to this frame and it will say
set the style attribute to nothing to
empty and that's it that's the only
difference a span so when we when we run
dipping after doing that click the only
thing we need to do to the Dom is we
need to find that attribute and we need
to set its value to zero likewise the
counter component is a little bit more
accomplished
we need to upkeep that count value
remember that's content from zero to one
and that content is inside of div and P
tags so we have a step in so we step
into a P a div tag then we step in to a
P tag and then we update that text and
then we step out and step out now how
does the system know that we're stepping
into a P tag how does a system know that
we're stepping into a div tag well
remember that output we looked at before
that big honkin output for counter
component these diff instructions I'm
not showing it to you here but they have
offsets and they say like step into the
one at offset of three or something like
that right and it ends up being like
these dips are very coupled to exactly
what state came before and exactly what
step state came afterwards so think
about that I'm not again I'm not showing
all the details here because I don't
want to make everybody's heads explode
but I want you to get the point which is
that the system is designed to produce
the really minimal set of changes that
need to happen it's fairly sophisticated
to guarantee that and we do that by
identifying exactly what parts of the
Dom need to change and changing only
those parts at no point do we like
generate new HTML and just paste over
something like we go by manipulating
things so benefits of dipping it's
really cheap all the stuff that we've
talked about here so far in that the
framework is doing on your hat on your
behalf is very comparatively inexpensive
compared to things like updating the Dom
or sending bytes over the network
components are designed to only render
if they have a reason usually that's
going to just work in your favor and
your components aren't going to do any
work if they don't have anything
interesting to do one of the nice side
effects of doing dipping is if your
component does rerender and it produces
the same output you'll get a zero diff
so there's nothing to do and it can
short-circuit very nicely and the things
that are comparatively expensive in
terms of the Blaser UI process are
network transmission of Dom updates
which we we sort of amortize by batching
and dama the actual Dom updates
themselves are comparatively expensive
so how does the server work and I'm
going to speed up a little bit here
because I want to make sure Steve has
time to do his demos and cool little
stuff and we're also going to leave a
little bit of time for questions so how
does this work when we introduce Blaser
server to the mix
well rendering with Blaser server how we
actually apply the updates to the UI how
we run your components how we figure out
what to change in the UI everything
you've heard so far is the same so the
process of how do we figure out what
operations to do on the UI totally the
same between web assembly and blazer
server adding the server just means that
the Dom updates have to go over the wire
so we have to send them over that signal
our connection that we talked about and
we choose signal R because it's got it's
bi-directional it's got low latency and
it's got a very low amount of overhead
per message in addition to that we use
the message pack format instead of
something more verbose like JSON so we
use a very optimized binary format to
transform these frames over the wire I'm
going to break from my prepared remarks
and just show a quick demo of this in
the interest of time so let's run this
up and I'm going to show you what's
happening in the UI here just to sort of
prove that that's what's happening so
I've got my counter page here that's
very exciting and I'm gonna I can't zoom
in any closer on that unfortunately and
I'm gonna find that area of the DOM and
then I'm gonna expand this you can see
our fancy span and you can see hopefully
the font size is is pretty good it's
it's kind of a challenge to make the
font size bigger in the developer tool
so you can see when I click this it's
gonna kind of flash on the screen so you
can see Chrome can tell you exactly what
changed in the DOM and it's because
we're only changing those parts now the
other piece of this that I want to
highlight here is I'll refresh this
because the network tab always wants you
to refresh things I'll refresh this and
you can see that I've got this web
socket over here and I can look at this
web socket and I can see all of these
messages that are coming through this
web sockets you can see we're getting a
243 bite down message and we're getting
a 27 message back and and so on so when
you keep clicking this you see these
messages fly and they're all sort of on
the order of like 200 250 bytes
something like that that's the size of
that payload that's saying update this
count and set the style attribute to two
empty that's what's going over the wire
and that's that 200 bytes so that's
that's roughly what the message format
is like the message format because it's
based on message pack which is a binary
format it's not human readable so we're
really going to look at it as far as how
do we do the server-side communication
how does this work so I can show that as
well when we do a when you do a
connection and when you browse to that
initial page you get this blob of HTML
back that's in part of the page and this
can be whether you're using pre
rendering with blazer or not but when we
run through your server-side code we say
well we're gonna put the counter
component here we're gonna put the app
component here so we generate in a
comment in the page the sort of set of
instructions for what the server can do
we call this a marker these markers are
encrypted payloads so it's something
that only the server will be able to
understand and really the reason why we
have encryption there is to prevent
tampering to prevent you from injecting
like sort of garbage data in there it
would be very hard or very impossible
for you to brute-force this and come up
with a data payload that's going to do
something different there also time
stamps so you can't really replay them
beyond like 30 seconds after when it was
issued so then the client opens that
WebSocket connection to the server and
it basically sends back this information
and says hey this is who I am and it's
the full list of instructions of what
the server needs to do to get you into
the sort of initialized state so in this
case the instructions go to the server
that say well my component that is the
root component of this app is you know
my site app go ahead and load that and
that's how the server gets into the same
state and then you're connected and
things start working so how this works
you get a signal our connection over
that connection you get a secret ID the
browser holds on to that secret ID and
can use it to reconnect if something
goes wrong and that's important because
on the server we have to retain the
ability to diff with the client so we
need a persistent connection to the
server because all your state and all
your components are in memory we will
hold on to your components in memory on
the server until you disconnect and
things timeout or until you gracefully
close so if you close the browser tab or
if you navigate away from the site for
instance will will detect that inside
the browser will send a message to the
server and will instantly kill all your
state on the server I already showed the
client-server communication let's
actually look at one more thing so when
you're using server-side Blaser and
these are sort of
debug level logs I don't expect anybody
to be able to really get what's going on
here but I think maybe if you look
carefully you can see some of the things
that we're talking about here so when I
click this button it sends a signal our
message to the server that's where my
cursor is right now that says hey the
mouse was clicked here on this button
then that goes to my event handler
that's event 3 it's Mouse event args and
you can see we render the counter we
render the fancy span we get a batch
batch number seven of size 217 bytes and
that sent to the client and then the
client acknowledges the batch and says
hey I got it I did the thing I applied
the update and that's roughly how
eventing and communication work in in
server-side laser cool cool so I think
I'm gonna wrap there and yield the rest
of my time to Steve you don't you don't
want it in the bandwidth thing oh we can
do the bandwidth thing so in case you've
been curious about performance of signal
are yeah let's let's go ahead and do
this so in case you've been curious
about this this is a question that we
get a lot that comes up a lot when we're
talking about server-side Blaser is
people people think about it really hard
and they say well that probably can't
work that probably is not going to have
good performance it probably is not
possible this is a comparison I made of
the bandwidth of some of the things that
you might use day to day so I gathered
this by using another code sample that I
didn't show here but I'm happy to show
anybody later I've got a form with like
five text fields on it and I'm just
typing in those text fields and
basically doing the kinds of things you
do in an enterprise or line of business
app and the Dom updates or the the diff
dips that are getting sent across the
wire per operation in that more
complicated case are more like 500 bytes
so if you think about I'm entering
things once a second on a form field
each of your connected clients in a
blazer server application is costing you
Oh point zero five kilobits per second
of bandwidth compared to something like
Spotify on desktop which is using 160
kilobytes or YouTube at its like worst
resolution using like a thousand
kilobits yeah so in a world where video
games can be streamed over the Internet
1080p or even 4k as Google are saying
you know or not to be surprising that we
can stream button clicks is not actually
that hard yeah
so if you want to if you want to
understand or think about how to plan
performance of a blazer server
application of the thing that actually
matters is latency so latency of more
than 200 to 250 milliseconds feels bad
it will start to feel laggy if you're
more than that amount fortunately it's
relatively easy to get latency better
than that but if your application
involves devices that are going to have
unreliable network connections or that
network connections with a lot of packet
loss Blaser is not a good a blazer
server is not a good choice for that
blazer client is a great choice
however most of most of our use cases
involve like being in our office
having a good internet connection being
close to the data center or some little
app that like 10 people are going to use
the the latency and the impact of the
Dom updates is going to depend on the
kind of interaction so if you intend to
build an application that's got a big
text field on it and you're gonna type
your diary of everything that happened
in your life in there it's gonna be 30
megabytes the performance of that is
going to be very poor because that's
something that has to be sent back and
forth over the wire time and time again
but for the kinds of applications that
people typically use build and use
inside businesses the the size of the
Dom updates is not a very big factor
you can design to make smaller updates
but that's more of a consideration for
people writing complicated controls like
forms or tables or filtering grids
however the performance consideration
that does matter is memory so because
every connected client reserves some
amount of memory and has their
components in memory on the server the
amount of memory that each of your that
your components use in your app and the
amount of memory that the framework uses
is a consideration that you have to care
a lot about so we did an experiment we
did some experiments with this before we
shipped Blaser we did this really cool
thing where we wrote a headless client
for testing Blaser
i'm not going to get incredibly deep
with it but basically we needed
something that we could test Blaser
better that with better than something
like selenium which is slow and heavy so
we wrote a client that uses signal art
to talk to Blaser directly and basically
simulates a client so that we could run
lots of them and we did an experiment on
Azure so a small vm for us a DSD 1 v 2
which is like a single-core small via
gracefully handled five-thousand
concurrent clients so that's five
thousand clients doing a very simple
forms thing with no degradation in
latency was once we got significantly
higher than five thousand clients that
we started to see the latency spiked and
that was mostly due to memory
consumption and garbage collection
pressure likewise we tried a much more
powerful VM and we were able to very
comfortably run 20,000 concurrent
clients on that on that VM so thanks
that's my bit I'm gonna hand things over
to Steve all right next app if you want
to help us out excellent
all right let's switch control hmm okay
afterwards if you don't mind yeah right
then so we can turn the screen back on
excellent right so during my part of
this talk I want to tell you some
slightly more advanced stuff about some
things with authorization and
authentication which is an interesting
topic that doesn't get a lot of coverage
before we really get into showing you
how to do stuff with it I want to show
you what we gonna give you out of the
box when you clear create a new laser
application from the project template
today you might have seen this you might
not so when you create a blazer server
application you get the choice to use
your tri-ball if you turn it on you get
to Bill to choose what authentication
method you want to use so if you click
on this button you'll see that we've got
a bunch of different options for you we
can let you use no authentication if you
want to you can use individual accounts
which are stored in a database inside
your application we also let you connect
to various cloud-based user identity
stores and finally we've got good old
windows authentication Steve are these
the same options as normal server-side
asp net core they are in fact the same
options at the same UI so if you have
any options that you're using with
server-side asp net core we expect them
to work with Blaser as well they will
indeed work yes because there's nothing
different when it comes to what's
happening at runtime with making this
work on the server so i'm going to
quickly show you what happens if we
create the store the option to use
individual user accounts stored inside
the application so when that project has
created itself and restored its packages
I can start this up in a browser and
what we'll hopefully see is something
that looks pretty familiar like a normal
standard blazer project you probably
seen this about a hundred times by now
the thing about it there's slightly
different to usual is that up here in
the top right you can see we've got
these register and login links so let's
say I want to login well I have to
really have to register myself first
because I don't have an account and when
I click that you see it goes over into
this slightly different looking UI and
this is supplied by a feature that's
built into asp net core on the server
it's called identity and it provides
birth and UI for user management as well
as the data store for it and that's
integrated with blazer on the server
there so let's register myself that's
not really my email address but it will
work well enough and type in a password
that's good enough for the password
policy when I first do that because I'm
the first ever person to use this site
it doesn't actually even have a database
yet so it's going to give me this error
message saying that I need to create the
database that won't happen if you deploy
to production but it does when you're
running locally so I've created my
database now and then I'll hit continue
or reload and then hopefully well let's
try that one more time when it's
finished creating the database then it
will let me in and you'll see I am
indeed logged in as that person and of
course I can do things like logout
I could log back in let's give my
username again
and we go okay so we've got a user
database and we've been able to keep
track of who's logged in and we could
now start using the normal blazer
programming model to produce different
UI depending on who's logged in and what
kind of capabilities and powers they
should have okay so that's what we've
got built into the box but what I think
I would like to for us to spend our time
doing now is going to a much more
advanced level and thinking about what
would happen if we couldn't use this
built-in system and we had to create
something else like it ourselves maybe
we want to create a really custom user
experience around logging in that
integrates with a you know a different
custom back-end data store right so
what's the scenario for our application
I do love having sort of gimmicky
scenarios for my demos so here's the one
that we're going to do here
a little application I've been working
on called mission control not a lot of
people know this but as well as being a
developer on the weekends I operate a
network of spies and they mostly work
around the New York you know the central
Manhattan area of New York that's
actually in my country did you know that
oh yeah I know okay
I actually yeah I was I wasn't sure if
you're confused now we apply quite an
influential role in the operations ago
country okay so obviously as a spy
master I need to keep track of where all
my spies are so I've got this
application here which for instance lets
me list where they all are and I know
what all their missions are that they're
currently dealing with and if I want a
slightly more graphically rich view of
it I can go over onto this agents screen
here and I get this cool 3d map that I
can kind of scroll around and see what
they're all up to I could zoom out and
get an overview so instance is Natalia
she's triggering the global banking
crisis so that was a while ago was oh oh
no this is the next one we look forward
to that yeah everyone's been waiting for
that for a while we we all want that
right and then we've got let's see we've
got agent K doing some things with
scoober equipment down there okay so
this list of information about my
agencies obviously very sensitive I
don't want it to fall into the wrong
hands so I want to protect it the first
and most important rule of any kind of
security relating to client-side
applications is that all of your
security enforcement happens on the
server it does not happen in the client
because nothing your client does can be
trusted people can always change the
code that's in your client they could
more easily just look at what network
requests it makes and then just modify
all the IDs and the payloads of the
requests if they want to you just can't
trust anything that the client will do
so if we want to lock this stuff down
we're going to have to do it on the
server so let's do that I'm gonna go
into my server and you can see I've got
this MVC application here that is
returning this hard-coded data but you
know in a real app that could do
something a little bit more interesting
and I'm going to use a very simple
built-in feature of a subpoena core on
the server to simply say that I want
this controller to be authorized which
means that you can only access the
methods on it if you are logged in and I
could add other criteria like roles and
policies and stuff but I don't really
need that right now
I'm just gonna do this and then let's
see what happens now if I come back to
my browser and try to reload now then
instead of getting this data I don't get
the data I just get this kind of
spinning thing that goes on forever
which is quite weird but why is that
happening
well we'll have a look and we see that
what's happening is the server is now
responding with 401 unauthorized which
is good right that's exactly what we
wanted this user is not logged in so
they should not be allowed to see that
data but what's not so good is that this
user experience is kind of insane right
now we're just showing this spinner
going forever and the users just waiting
and waiting so what we would like to do
is if the users not logged in display a
nice message to tell them why they can't
see this data and that's pretty easy to
do because in the same way that we use
this authorized attribute on the server
we can use the exact same attribute in
our client side or you know in our
components that are running on Blaser
which is itself either running
client-side in web assembly or server
side it doesn't matter you're producing
this client like experience and we can
use these same attributes on it so I'm
going to go to the thing that renders my
list of agents here and I'm not going to
go through all the code here if you want
to learn more about blazars programming
model and what these kind of components
are and how you set up events and stuff
well you can go and read some
documentation about that I just want to
assume that we know some of that stuff
and try building some UI inside it so
I'm going to add an attribute right here
which is the authorize attribute and
that's going to tell Blaser that I want
people to only be able to go to this
page if they're logged in so if I reload
now then instead of seeing that
squirrely thing and now get this nice
message only logged in mission
commanders may access this area now you
will be reassured to know that's not the
built in default message in our system
that's something that I've customized
and if you're wondering where I
customized that it's right here in my
root component so if you've not seen
blazes Rooter before this is usually
kept more or less the top level of you
in your application and it's responsible
for knowing what the current URL is and
observing when that URL changes and then
displaying different pages depending on
that
and we can say things like if there is a
page or if there isn't a page will
display this message if there is then
we'll do this other stuff and the other
stuff that I want to do here is use this
thing called authorized route view and
that's built-in and what that does is it
checks whether or not the page that
corresponds to your URL whether you can
satisfy the authorization criteria for
it and if you can't obviously it
displays this message okay right so I
want to be able to do some real
authorization now and some real log
again and such but the question we have
to ask ourselves is what does it even
mean to log in what is our
authentication protocol well let's
imagine that we've been given a protocol
that we have to integrate with we don't
control this protocol someone else has
done it we've just got to build a UI for
it and the protocol that we're going to
have looks a bit like this okay so we're
going to have our client-side blazer
application and in order to authenticate
itself with a server it's going to have
to send a request to the server with a
username and password and what we expect
the server to send us back in this case
is going to be a JSON web token that's a
pretty standard thing within the
industry there are various different
flows you can use for controlling how
the client gets the tokens from the
server the one I'm going to do here is a
bit like password grant flow but there's
quite a lot of subtleties to it and if
you want to learn more you can go and
read some docs from the OAuth group or
other people and they'll tell you about
how this sort of thing is supposed to
work but we're going to have a pretty
simple implementation right here that
gets that token and then when we want to
access some protected resources such as
our list of agents
we'll send that token inside the request
to the server as a bearer header and if
the server likes the token that we've
sent then it's going to be willing to
send back this protected data to us okay
so how can we get into a situation where
we've got the Turki well we need to make
the user login right then first thing I
want to do as part of logging in is
actually show what the users login
status is at the moment I'm just
displaying this hard coded message let's
see where that comes from
shall we inside my list of components
here I've got one called login display
and as
can see it's just got this hard coded
message insider now what I want to do is
display a different bit of output
depending on whether the users logged in
or not and I can do that using this
built-in thing called authorize view
don't know why the scales changed okay
and the authorized view lets us produced
different outputs so if the users
authorize we're going to display hello
and we'll say that name and if they're
not then we're gonna just tell them that
they're logged out okay let's see if
that actually works I am logged out at
the moment so when I reload hopefully it
will now say you're logged out good
that's working we're happy with that
quick question though how does the
client know whether we're logged in or
not just where does it get that
information from is it asking the server
does it somehow just magically know well
let me show you the thing that
determines whether you're logged in or
logged out or what your authentication
stay is as far as the client is
concerned is a DI service a dependency
injection service and we've got a built
in implementation of this the
authentication state provider if you're
using server-side laser but if you're
using blazer on webassembly which I am
here then there is no built in
implementation because what does it mean
to be logged in or logged out you need
to define a definition for that so I've
created an implementation of this called
token authentication state provider
because good we're going to be working
with JSON web tokens in a bit and the
implementation for that isn't very much
all it's doing is is overriding this
method called get authentication stay
async and we're hard-coding the idea
that we're logged out so here's a claims
identity which is a standard concept in
don't net it's been forever and that
describes information about the user and
an empty one like this just means
someone who's logged out so that's my
default hard-coded status I'm logged out
if I wanted to I could change this to
hard code the idea that I'm logged in
instead so let me do that just to show
you what this will do I'm gonna create a
different claims identity that hard
codes the idea that my name is Steve and
I've already been authenticated using
this fake off type which is not a real
thing I've just made it up but that's
what my client-side application is now
going to believe is the case for this
user so if I go back and I read
Lode now then instead of you're logged
out it now says hello Steve which is
quite a good improvement okay so does
that mean we can now fetch the list of
agents from the server let's find out
I'll try to do that and the answer is no
we still despite the client thinking
that we're logged in we still can't get
that data and the server is still
responding with 401 unauthorized just
because the client thinks we're logged
in that is not going to convince the
server we'd still didn't provide a valid
token okay so let's try and get a valid
token I'll remove that thing about being
logged in as Steve I'll just go back to
where we were before so it says I'm
logged out again and now I want to
change this up here so that it displays
a button for logging in so I'm going to
go back to my what is it now my login
display and I'm going to change what
we've got there a little bit to have a
little bit more stuff going on all right
so now if you're authorized again will
display that your username and if you're
not authorized we're going to display a
message that say a button that says
login and if you're wondering what all
these MDC things are well this is coming
from a nougat package that I've
installed and that's what's providing
all this attractive UI this has this
material design style and this MDC
stands for material design components so
that's coming from an external package
in case you were wondering but anyway
that's how I'm going to display a login
button
you might also be wondering what this
thing is a login dialog is that
something that's built into blazer the
answer is no it's not that's one of my
components that I've defined in my
application right here so let me show
you what that's going to do when that
renders hopefully now we're going to see
this button to login up in the top right
and when I click on that it's going to
display this attractive login dialog
which has got some nice features in it
such as some validation so if I click
this you'll see it says you know you
didn't fill that out what are you doing
and I'll start trying to fill this in
and you see the status starts to change
and that's all very nice so what's going
to happen if I click on login shall we
find out what happens is we get an
exception not implement an exception
okay so we've obviously not finished
doing our job just yet let's go and see
why we got that exception in fact what
is inside this login dialog well
there is quite a lot of code in this and
I appreciate that it might seem a little
overwhelming at first but don't worry
I'll walk you through it it's not that
bad really
so this form on the screen here is an
example of a data entry process and so
I'm using Blazers built-in forms and
validation system and that is based
around this built-in component called
edit form that keeps track of an edit
operation that is taking place such as
which fields are dirty which fields have
got validation messages associated with
them things like that and we have to
tell it which model object we want to
validate when this form gets submitted
so I've got this credentials thing and
down here that's what defined as an
instance of login credentials a custom
type in my application I'll show you
that you'll see it's not got very much
going on it's just got user name and
password and I've got these validation
attributes on it so that's why
validation rules were applied and to
edit an instance of login credentials
I'm using some form fields so I've got a
text field here that's bound to the user
name property on my model I've also got
a thing that will display any validation
messages associated with that field then
what else we've got down here we've got
some buttons that are going to submit
the form and up at the top we're saying
that when the form is submitted
if all the validation rules are
satisfied then we'll call this method
submit credentials and that is defined
down here and that's the thing that was
throwing they're not implemented
exception that we saw before okay so
what do we need to do well remember the
protocol we want to send our credentials
to the backend server and it's going to
return a JSON web token to us if our
credentials are good so let me put in a
little bit of implementation for that
I'm going to use the HTTP client to post
in JSON format to the server this was it
the login credentials the credentials
object there so that will get JSON
serialized and let's just mark this as
async and the result that comes back
from there is going to be an instance of
login result that is simply just the
JSON web token if the server is happy
with us then we'll check whether the
server seems to be happy in other words
is that token all or not and if it's not
then we think okay good we're logged
I don't know what to do yet all I'm
going to do right now is just print that
token to the console so that we can see
it let's try it out shall we
I'm going to once again try to log in
and I'm going to enter a bad password
initially so the server will reply with
an empty token and will display that
message to the user and then if I change
it to a good password then that form
will go away and will display this token
here everybody it's a little picture of
that token yeah yeah this is my secret
token now if you've not seen a JSON web
token before this is an industry
standard thing it's a way of encoding a
bunch of claims about a user in an
encrypted or and signed way so if you're
wondering what's inside it we've got
three parts we've got this first part up
to that first dot we've got another part
that goes down to this next dot and then
there's a third part after it and each
one of those parts is some base64
encoded data so shall we have a look
what's inside there I'm going to go to
this website called base64 decode dog
which is awesome so that's just what I
want right now
and I'm going to paste that base64 stuff
in there and then I'll click decode and
we'll see that what was inside er is
this so it contains some JSON and we've
got this claim called name and it says
that my name is Steve and that this
token is going to expire to a certain
point in the future and we've got some
other information as well now if you're
thinking ah that means I can easily make
tokens that say that my name is anything
I want that's cool you can't really
because the third part of this token if
I remember correctly is a signature from
the server so when you send that back to
the server it will be able to validate
that it really did issue this token and
it can check the expiry date and things
like that okay so we've got our token
now we want to actually use it in some
way I want to use that to update my
authentication state as far as the
client is concerned and that means
pausing the information out of this
token and using it in our authentication
state provider okay so I want to
centralize all the stuff about using a
token here in this token authentication
state provider so instead of printing
this to the console I want to just pass
that on to my my thing whose name is too
long to keep repeating so I'm gonna
send that token over there and in order
to be able to do that I better actually
in import or inject an instance of this
into my component so let me just drop
another little bit of code up here
and inject one of these authentication
state providers so that I can call this
set oaken async method on it but I
haven't implemented this method yet
hence the red squiggly thing let's go
over here what are we going to do with
this token well the first thing I'm
going to do is just store it in memory
so I'm going to define a field to hold
it just temporarily in memory and I'm
going to store the value on there and
then I'm going to tell blazer that the
authentication state has changed and so
anything that depends on authentication
state needs to refresh at this point
okay and then instead of hard-coding the
idea that I'm always logged out I want
to pass stuff from that token and use
that as the authentication state so I'm
saying if the token is null are empty
then we'll behave as if you're logged
out but otherwise I want to pause the
claims out of that token and that's
pretty easy it just means splitting it
on the dots doing a base64 decode and
then parsing the JSON data that I just
showed you before and that then becomes
my authentication state as far as the
client is concerned so now when I log in
hopefully it will actually display that
in the UI
it says hello Steve you're left in and
that's pretty cool and you see that the
rest of the UI is also updated and it's
now trying to fetch the data from the
server which is still not working but
we'll get to that in a minute we've got
a couple of problems the first problem
is that because I've only stored this
token temporarily in memory as soon as i
refresh my page I instantly become
logged out again because the token
wasn't really stored anywhere so where
should we store this token well a
convenient place for a client-side
application is the browser's local
storage and I can do that quite easily
this authentication state provider is a
dependency injection service so it can
depend on other services too and I'm
going to make it depend on having a
JavaScript runtime and I can use that to
make calls into JavaScript for example
to store this token in the
so what I'm gonna do is I'll get rid of
my temporary in memory store altogether
won't have a double line break because
Ryan gets mad
well James gets mad oh yeah yeah sorry
just over there yeah yeah and then
instead of storing my token in that
field I'm going to call a method on
JavaScript one time I'm gonna say we're
going to call the standard JavaScript
API local storage say item the key will
be auth token and the value will be the
token itself and then when I want to
know what the value of that token is I'm
going to read it back from JavaScript as
well and that's just as easy we make a
call on J s runtime to say local storage
getitem using the key auth token so now
hopefully that will be stored
persistently in the browser let's see
I'm going to log in again and then I'm
going to refresh once again and this
time I stay logged in I know you can't
really see anything happen but really I
did refresh there we go
I'm afraid I've done something crazy
here anyway right it did work and I'm
still logged in that's good but sadly
I'm now trapped forever
I can't log out because I have an
implemented logout let's do a quick
logout feature shall we on our login
dialog we've got a button click handler
for logout which throws at the moment
and I'm simply going to tell it that I
want it to overwrite the current token
with an empty string and that will be
sufficient to make me get logged out as
long as I mark that as a sink thank you
right let's see if I can log myself out
now so I'm still logged in I click the
button and I'm logged out brilliant and
the rest of the UI automatically updated
all right so we're very nearly there now
what's not working yet let's find out
I'm going to try once again to log in
and get my data and you'll see that I
still don't get my data and if we look
at the browser console you'll see still
unbelievably despite all the hard work
we've done the server is still not happy
it still says 401 unauthorized why is
that because we are still not sending
the token in our request to the server
so let's do that now we've got the token
first I'm going to have to be able to
expose that token to other code in my
application so I'm going to do a little
bit reef
factoring using this extract method tool
here I'm going to extract a method
called get token async like that and
then I'm going to mark that as public so
I can use it elsewhere in my application
and then over on one of the places where
I want to get some data I'll be able to
call it so let's go to inside my pages
I'll go to my agents list and you can
see I'm already injecting my token
provider in here so now I can get that
token from my provider using the get
token async method and then when we make
this outbound HTTP request I'm going to
also add an authentication header called
bearer with this token value all right
let's see if finally we can actually
fetch our super secret data from the
server now that we're logged in and we
can so finally the server accepts that
we're logged in and all the other stuff
is going to work so if I hit logout
instantly it's going to switch over to
this mode it didn't have to reload the
page it just does it if I log in again
then my data is going to come back and
all the authentication decisions are
still being made on the client on the
server obviously okay so that is the
flow that I wanted to show you I hope
that gives you a sense of how you could
create a custom UI flow corresponding to
whatever kind of back-end authentication
service you might need so that's enough
about that now we've got a little bit of
time left and we had an idea for what we
could do we're just going to switch back
to the other laptop if that's all right
is that okay right
there you go
okay okay great so we've got a couple
minutes for QA we'll probably be hanging
around afterwards the party a little bit
too if you want to talk to us but shout
out shout out your questions I have
pre-canned ones that people can either
upload by asking or if nobody has
questions we'll just talk about this
stuff what do you all night
yeah okay so the question is about the
performance of the different algorithm
how it might compare to other frameworks
yes so we've thought about this very
carefully it's been one of the first
things that we started with when we work
it on Blaser in the first place and the
good news is that because of the way
that our system works we have got an
unfair advantage that allows us to be
significantly faster than other things
and the unfair advantage that we've got
is that we've got a compile step going
on and so you remember those sequence
numbers that Ryan showed you on his
slide those are inserted automatically
by the compiler and that gives us a lot
of extra information that we can use at
run time during dipping so when we do
dipping over your tree structure we can
do it in an order n time it's for purely
linear operation to do that death which
is ridiculously fast compared with a
typical tree difficult for men squared
to n to the fourth power depending on
what kind of operations you support so
yes we have we have it very easy to do
those deaths and in most cases we're
going to be able to significantly
outperform most things when you can
count it based on number of operations
performed those
sure okay the question is about the
adoption level of web assembly in
browsers particularly mobile and the
answer to that is that web assembly has
been supported in the two main mobile
platforms iOS and Android for a long
time by now I think it was first in iOS
version 11 which is quite a while ago
and it's it's been in android for even
longer so it's it's basically very very
widely available more or less Universal
as for the question of whether blazer
server is a better fit for doing things
on mobile as well it really depends that
the key advantages that blazer server is
going to have is more to do with the
bandwidth required for getting that
initial page to show up so blazer server
involves transferring a lot less data
over the network to startup and it's
also taking the load off the client when
it comes to actually running all the UI
update operations and diffing and stuff
so blazer server can perform better on
low-end mobile devices if they've got a
good network connection
right question do you on a second I'm
sure so the question was about scaling
and about whether or not blazer has any
built-in mechanisms for scaling your
memory or sort of sharing storage using
offloading a store like Redis so the
reason why we don't have something like
that is we don't have something like
that because the thing that we have in
memory is your instances of components
so it's not a prescriptive data
structure kind of thing we haven't found
the need to do that because we're just
basically using sticky sessions at the
load balancer so like the signal our
service does stickiness and you're
connected so like there's no need to
necessarily like move you to another
node while you're connected is that
address your question or yeah it's gone
so you can use other mechanisms for that
you could use reticence out of your app
for the things you want to save as well
and we've got some Docs and guidance on
that down front okay the question is can
you use blaze a client with an on an on
net server it was it an omelet okay so
to clarify when you use blaze a client
what you're serving to the browser is
just static files as far as the server
is concerned it does not matter at all
wise on the server you don't need it to
be and it have anything ology Blaser you
don't even need it to be a dotnet server
you could serve it from you know an ojs
server I should a demo yesterday of
serving a blazer client application from
github pages it's completely
uninteresting to the server what the
content is it's just static files in the
back
um the scenario you're describing where
an outbound HTTP request is blocking
things is very unfamiliar to me because
you can't do blocking HTTP requests in
the client even if you want to the only
kind of HTTP requests you can do are
asynchronous so I think something
different must have been happen in your
situation but I can't really guess what
it is if you want come and chat to us
afterwards and we'll try and help you
figure that out we're about at time so
we'll take one more don't fret
sorry the question again threading ohm
on training in web assembly yeah sure
okay so the initial the question is
what's the state of multi-threading
support in web assembly great question
so when the first version of web
assembly came out it did not have any
kind of concept of multi-threading it
was a purely single threaded
specification and that's the thing that
is currently rolled out into like all
the browsers in the world the as for
adding actual threading support there is
a proposal for how that should work and
it's at quite an advanced stage already
so advanced in fact that it's already
been shipped inside Chrome Google has
been pushing that along quite well so I
don't know how quickly that's going to
come to other browsers but it you know
it's obviously making its way along
quite well as for support within Blaser
that's not something we've started
taking advantage of yet the mono team
who provides the mono web assembly
runtime for us they've been working
quite hard on making sure that they can
attach Nets concept of threading on to
the new web assembly threading and
apparently that works really well but we
haven't started trying to use it yet in
terms of how it affects you as a
developer the programming model that
we've designed so far is all designed
around the traditional single threaded
model that most client-side developers
are familiar with so there isn't really
much of a need for having multiple
threads concurrently if you're just
doing a bunch of things with button
clicks and HTTP requests and stuff the
scenario you might want to is in more
advanced scenarios where you're doing
some kind of background competition that
absolutely can't be interrupted for some
reason and for that you would have to
find a way of modeling that with
asynchrony today
we do expect to get the multi-threading
support from on our web assembly over
the next coming months okay thanks
[Applause]